so something that's going on this summer
which I do not support is salt and straw
the ice cream place has lost their
[__] mind these are some of their
flavors this summer chocolate potato
salad
spiced mustard ice cream potato chip
cookies fudge what the [__] is going on
Dwayne Johnson and the [__] lesbian
wiccans that own salt and straw cinnamon
and honey Fried Chicken served by whites
the first one I'm trying is uh chocolate
potato salad and this is the mustard
flavored ice cream which I think is
probably heinous now it would be a great
bit if I ate four pints like if I every
single pint I just ate the entire pint
as I was talking about how gross it is I
was like this is horrible